the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
hey good morning everybody uh happy
thursday it's
august 4th
and you know thanks for taking the time
out to come to today's special session
on how to find hidden training
opportunities using order flow you know
order flow in my opinion is one of the
best ways that traders can view the
market and today i'm going to share with
you uh several things i'm going to spend
some time teaching you how order flow
works how to find hidden trading
opportunities in the order flow data
and explain sort of the different types
of orders
that can give you an edge in the market
now i'm talking about order specifically
as opposed to the order flow because you
know order flow originates from the
orders and sometimes people don't uh
distinguish between
uh you know the different types of
orders that are there in the market
i'm going to share with you some tips on
how to use the order flow data and i'm
gonna share some successful strategies
for
trading order flow
so you know just a brief
background on who i am you know and you
know why i think you should listen to me
because you know i've been trading you
know i've been involved in the market
since the early 1990s i started on the
cme trading for the chicago merc until x
trading
exchange uh trading floor with deanwater
rounds i literally started at the bottom
and i worked my way up through various
trading desks you know a couple years at
the edf man trading desk in chicago
um
commerce bank also in chicago as a
licensed ux trader there
and i had the futures trading desk at
cargill i even went to singapore to set
up a trading desk for them when they
exchanged in singapore the the cymix was
closing down and going fully electronic
and after cargill i spent eight years as
vice president of futures trading at jp
morgan now in 2015 i started uh writing
a book on trading order flow and i was
the software that i had been using
because i was trading for myself after i
left jpmorgan
in 2013.
you know the software was pretty basic
it didn't do
well let's say it didn't do what it did
is it just presented the data for you
okay
but i know that software
can do a lot more than that and so i sat
down with the programmer as as i was
writing my book and i said you know this
is the way that i analyze the order flow
can you put some of this analysis into
soft into the software to highlight to
traders
you know where
the aggressive buyers are where the
aggressive sellers are where
market is getting weaker in terms of
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
you know different things related to the
volume that's actually trading in the
market to you know improve my trading
results and i didn't expect to become a
software vendor you know setting up this
company order flows but when i started
sharing my charts with other traders
they were seeing
you know it was like the you know world
was opening up in front of them you know
they were starting to see things that
they had never seen before in the order
flow and that's how um the overflow
software company began
and again you know it's the software
that i created but the reason i'm
talking about it is because the charts
you're going to see in this presentation
are based off of the order flow trader
charts but you're going to see how
quickly and easily you can see things in
the order flow now you know the whole
point of doing a presentation like this
is to teach you what to see so whether
you're using my software or any other
order flow footprint software you should
be able to see the same things
okay because that's what it comes down
to is being able to identify what's
happening in the market
so before we jump in you know just a
brief disclaimer right we're all
grown-ups right we're all adults we do
understand that trading involves risk
and only risk capital should be used for
trading okay don't go out and you know
trade with your rent money that's due
next month
okay because you're putting yourself
under a lot of undue pressure so again
just to recap what i'll be talking about
is understand how order flow works how
to find hidden trading opportunities in
the order flow data and when i talk
about hidden training opportunities you
know it's things that you're going to be
able to see that that people that are
looking at a normal candlestick or bar
chart just aren't able to see
and discuss the different types of
orders and they are going to give you an
edge in the market you know the
different types of orders that are out
there being traded
do have an effect on how the market
moves
and i'll share with you some tips on how
to use order flow data to your advantage
and i'll share with you a couple
successful strategies for trading order
for things that you can take away and
look for
in the market in your own analysis
so
understanding how order flow works
now trading is a lot like life right the
more you understand how it works the
easier it becomes right the trading
world is full of jargon and complicated
concepts you know everyone i'll go this
i'll go that but once you start to peel
back the layers it's not as daunting as
it seems right it's you know people used
to have this
there's you know have this image of
traders you know like all that you know
they're mathematicians or you know
things like that and you have access to
information that nobody else has well
now we're very
we're sort of in the information age
everyone has access to information
and levels of information that were just
weren't available to the retail traders
before
but the key to
doing it is take it one step at a time
and be patient right you remember rome
wasn't built in a day and neither is a
successful trading career but if you
want to put in the time and effort
you're going to be amazed at how quickly
things start to click into place and
that's really the whole point right you
want to be able to recognize what's
happening in the market
simply by looking at how the market is
trading and order flow is the one thing
that gets you as close to the market as
possible so this is a trading dome right
the depth of the market we're all
familiar with what this is we've all
seen it in one shape or form this is
from ninjatrader right my software runs
on ninjatrader but again you know we're
all familiar with what a trading domain
is right it shows you the best bid shows
you the best offer shows you the
quantity on the bid it shows you the
quantity on the offer and it shows you
the bids
and quantities below the best bid and it
shows you the quantities
and offer at different prices above the
best offer
now most people don't really think about
what this means okay so if you're
working a bid
right you're what's called a passive
buyer if you're working an offer you're
what's considered a passive seller now
think of it this way okay the easiest
way to think of it is you want to buy a
house
you go online you go to realtor.com or
whatever
you know website you like to look at
for homes and you see all these homes
listed here different prices well yeah
those sellers they're
putting it out there they're saying you
know what this is my home this is what i
think it's worth they're a passive
seller they're waiting for somebody to
come up and be aggressive someone to
cross this big offer line and pay their
price
now
what you don't have right on those
realty websites is you don't have people
putting bids in
but instead you know a buyer will go
visit a house that's you know on sale
for at 39 54. we'll call it and
you know he'll like the house you know
yeah you know what you know i watch all
these shows on tv where everyone goes
visits houses and decides which ones to
buy and they put a bid in right they're
going to be a passive buyer so you know
the house is offered at 39.54
they'll put a bid at 39.53 they they're
going to be a passive buyer in that
sense now
over the last year or so you know in
many parts of the world especially the
u.s housing market has been on fire so
the house that's offered at 39.54
it's got a lot of people want to buy it
now they're instead of being a passive
buyer say you know what i'm gonna bid
39.53 and hope the seller comes down
what they're gonna do is yeah
i know that if i i just visited eight
other houses and i tried to buy six of
them and i lost out on them people are
gonna be you know they're trying to sell
the house at 39.54 i'm going to be
aggressive i'm just going here's my
here's my offer 39.54
and buy it right they're not going to
mess around trying to work a bid or
anything like that so you know you have
different types of buyers and different
types of sellers you have passive buyers
you have aggressive buyers you have
passive sellers you have aggressive
sellers now when they trade
each trade shows up in the time and
sales
right and you're going to see you know
the time and sales
will have different colors right some
trades will be in green some will be in
this is orange or reddish you know and
there's even some that are designated by
other colors like like pink if it's a
new high or a new low
but
trades that happen
you know that are red are
aggressive sells people selling into the
passive bids trades that are green are
aggressive buys people that are buying
the offer so this is information that
you can use
right as a trader
it's available to you people say you
know what difference why do i need to
know that right i'm looking at my
candlestick chart and you know i can see
where price is trading that's all i need
to see
okay you know that's basic though right
you where's the information that you're
seeing on the dome on the time and sales
where the aggressive traders are you
know is is this price being
absorbed right are you seeing a lot of
volume go through at a level you know
there's all this information that's
available to you as a trader that you
should be using rather than just seeing
well i see price opened um you know at
39.55 or the bar open at 39.55 traded up
to 56
and then had a low of 54 and a half and
again we closed at 55.
the other that's
that's just basic information now if you
knew that
you know the market you know opened up
and then there was it spiked up on very
light volume came back down
closed you know in the middle that's
information right if you're looking at
you know say down here and you're seeing
all aggressive you know massive
aggressive buying strong aggressive
buying you're going to have a good
feeling that this market's going to
continue in that direction because you
have aggressive buyers
right now
another thing you know you have double
tops right what's happening at double
tops you know are there is there strong
buying or is it weak buying is the last
buyer bought things like that and all
that information is available to you if
you
know how to
use it and the best way to use it is on
a order flow footprint chart so that you
can see
you know the volume that's trading at
price and how aggressive it was or not
you know because markets exist to
facilitate trade okay and most of the
trade that goes through
is just the normal trading activity in
the market but there are times where
traders get aggressive for one reason or
another and that's what you want to look
for as well as you know areas where
there's heavy absorption right and the
only way you're going to tell if there's
absorption is by looking at the volume
traded at price you also want to see
where there's you know price rejection
you know the opposite of absorption
where there's very little volume being
traded at price because as you know you
know whether it's i'm not just talking
about you know in trading but if you've
ever run a business
the higher you raise your prices the
less
things that you know the less business
you're going to do
and it's the same way in the market
right the higher the market goes the
less buyers generally there are going to
be eventually you know the market's
going to top out and start to move down
so looking at volume it's a very
important aspect of the markets
now within
the footprint chart
right the way you
categorize the data that you're seeing
going through it's going to give you a
lot more data points to analyze there's
delta right which is the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers right it's one thing to say well
there's aggressive buyers here in
aggressive sellers but you want a way to
put it in in an easy to read format and
that's what delta is now you also have
max delta and min delta
max delta is how strong the aggressive
buyers were at one point in a bar
min delta is how strong
the aggressive sellers were in the bar
cumulative delta is the running delta
total sort of the running total between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
for the day
you also have point of control
which is the price level in a bar with
the most volume
you also have imbalances imbalances are
when you have
more aggressive sellers than buyers or
vice versa more aggressive sellers
than buyers right did i say that right
more aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers and the opposite more aggressive
sellers than aggressive buyers and the
best part is
all this data
is generated from what's actually
trading
right you're not using trend lines and
you know forms of analysis of what
happened
you know yesterday or five hours ago
you're using information based off of
what is trading in the market right now
so what do you think is going to be more
useful
knowing when there are aggressive
traders
and trading is taking place
or only knowing the last traded price
the open the high the load close
well knowing where the aggressive
traders are because what's going to move
the market it's not going you know
knowing simply where the open high low
closes is going to tell you which way
the market's moving it's where the
aggressive traders are
and in the direction that they're
trading is going to give you clues as to
where the market is moving and that
brings us into our next point on finding
hidden trading opportunities in the
order flow data
and you know sort of the way i i look at
it is
you know when you're looking at the
order flow data it's it sort of gives
you a different perspective of what's
happening in the market that other
traders just aren't seeing because
because again
most traders are only looking at open
high low close but once you're able to
see inside the bar so to speak seeing
where the the movements are happening
internally it's going to give you a
different aspect you know just as you
know you look here at this picture well
it's a dock
okay you turn it sideways
or the other way on the other axis it
looks like a rabbit
okay and it's the same thing with the
market you know sometimes you know just
looking at it a little bit different is
going to give you insight into the
market that you didn't just didn't have
before
whereas everyone sees a duck you're
seeing a rabbit
right and it's going to give you an edge
over them now 99 of traders use normal
candlestick charts which only give them
the four data points open high low close
but if you go back to the days of pit
trading right you know the pit is in the
middle and there's all these guys on the
side
sending in orders to the pit that's the
order flow right people would
fight on the floors to stand you know on
the top steps so they can see the the
guys flashing in the orange hey buy a
thousand
sell 500 seeing that order flow come
into the market is why exchanges
memberships were costing hundreds of
thousands of dollars back in the days of
open outcry
right because you had access to see that
order flow that people sitting off the
floor in an office looking at a screen
seeing just the open high low close
weren't seeing
so
what you want to be asking when you're
looking at the order flow
is what's going on basically where is
the trading taking place was it on the
bid was it on the offer there are many
ways to use this data you know you
should always be asking yourself these
questions you know when a market is
making a new high or new low
how is it doing it is it doing it on
heavy volume is it doing on average
volume is it doing it on light volume
because that's going to give you
insights into potential market turning
points
right or what about when a market is
coming into a support or resistance
level
is there heavy trading going on or is it
just testing it right these this is
valuable information that you're just
not going to see on a normal
bar chart right like this was
yesterday in crude oil right we hit our
high came off started making you know a
move back up to this high
and then it didn't go anywhere and then
it sold off i had a nice selloff of
about two dollars very quickly in about
20 minutes it dropped two dollars
but if you're looking at the order flow
you could recognize what was happening
right up in here right now you know
people will draw a trend line you know
here or they'll say well this is where
your support and you know you're going
to get short here okay fine you know
that's a bit of a stretch but if you're
watching it what's happening in here you
know that prices
the way the market is reacting is it's
not bullish it's bearish
and you can get short as close to the
top of this move as possible rather than
waiting for trend lines to get broken
you know a market's already moving you
could get short
a lot sooner and the bonus part is
since you're getting into a trade much
sooner your stop isn't as wide as it
would be if you're using a traditional
um
form of analysis right because you know
if you're drawing a trend line here at 9
where's your stop going to be well it's
probably going to be up here above this
high 96 you know 60. but if you're
getting short up here at 96.40 based off
what's happening in the order flow
you're still using the same stop
but instead of it being a 60 tick stop
you're you're getting short at 40 now
your stop is up at 60. you only have 20
tick stop to catch the same move
now this is the order flow what's
happening in here
and i'll get into this you know a little
bit more in depth as we go along
is we're coming back up towards the high
this green line is our high
and you know we're seeing very thin
volumes happening up here at the top you
know you've seen one contract trade two
contracts
two contracts right you're seeing
aggressive selling you're seeing selling
imbalances right that's these red
numbers in the bar right you're seeing
negative delta
okay so you're seeing all these signs of
negative order flow that's telling you
you know what this trade is to the short
side
and you can get short in here you know
96 35 96 40. again with your stop up
here and just above 96.57 as opposed to
waiting for this market to break down
you know 40 more cents before you
convince that
this market's going down
this is e-mini's what is this this is
yesterday's also right this is going
into the close right just made it like a
new high here
and then it's just sort of stalled out
around and then it dropped
you know from
67 area all the way down into the 50s
again pretty quick pretty dramatic move
okay well when you're up here near a
high you always have to ask you know
what's the order flow look like is it
bullish is it bearish you know are we
going to keep going up or are we going
to go sideways or potentially reverse
because you know if you're you're high
in the day and you're going to reverse
you know it could set up a beautiful
trade a big trade for you
and
what you're seeing up here at the high
is negative order flow
right right before it broke down going
into the close
so you know we made the new high we've
got a nice positive delta then we're
just off our highs we're staying off our
highs and it's kind of mixed smallish
delta some more buying you know positive
deltas
negative delta positive positive and
then it's just all negative negative as
you're just going along the high here so
this is the high of the day 4170 we're
just trading you know three points four
points off our high
and all of a sudden you just seen
negative delta negative delta negative
delta negative delta and the thing is
this delta it's not negative like ah
it's just a small number it's quite
strong
you know it's 600 it's 500 it's 900 it's
a thousand
right so you know you're up here at the
high of the day
and you got some strong selling going in
knowing that you have strong selling
coming in at the height of the day one
you know we're probably not going any
higher
two
maybe you go sideways or three
go short so if you know that one you're
not going higher you're definitely not
going to get it long
maybe you go sideways okay
or go short so
two out of three sideways are short
you're pretty safe and taking that trade
all right because if you're just going
sideways okay you could scratch the
trade or take a small loss or maybe
squeeze out a small winner on a sideways
move
or
catch
the nice move down
right the the 10-15 point move down that
happened pretty quick and that's just by
recognizing that you know as we're stuck
here near the high and not going
anywhere that this aggressive selling is
coming into the market in terms of by
looking at the deltas
this is sort of you know this was uh the
day before then the second um it was
that wednesday
or sorry tuesday and you had this nice
big push down and then the market
rallied off that and people say well
yeah you know you got that candlestick
it's a pin bar okay fine why didn't this
pin bar really work out why didn't this
pin bar really work out right i mean
it's
you've got three
two of them didn't work out you know one
did but if you're looking at the order
flow what you're seeing manifest in this
order flow was actually very bullish
right it's a big move down
and on a big move down right you're
going to expect to see
strong selling
and you did
the min delta was minus 2200
but it closed just at 278.
so what's that telling you right you had
strong selling down here this is going
into the low of the day strong selling 2
200 sellers at one point in this bar as
we're making that low
but in this bar that's why i talk about
hidden opportunities
it reversed it went from minus 2200 and
it closed just at 200. it was like 278
but
not only you had the strong aggressive
selling 2 000 sellers but then you
actually had 2 000 buyers come into the
market
and you know if you're just looking at
it you're just seeing oh this is just a
red candle down
you know
you're not getting too enthused about it
other than the long wick but if you're
watching the order flow you're getting
super excited because
one
you know that there's heavy sellers in
that bar
right
but you know that heavy strong buyers
came in and this is something that a lot
of people sort of scratch the surface on
with order flow but don't really go
deeper they just look at the headline
number of 278 the negative 278 well it's
got negative delta
well yeah it's got negative delta
but the delta was much more negative at
one point
all right it was minus 2200
and it only closed at minus 200 so it's
telling you there's a shift in that bar
from heavy aggressive selling to heavy
aggressive buying and this is the best
one because it's hidden in there right
it's just still negative delta sometimes
you see it turn positive and bar closes
positive and it's a little bit more
obvious but when a bar eats back
almost all its negative selling
and closes somewhere near zero or even
positive that's a strong sign right so
i'm not surprised to see that move that
we saw yesterday or
tuesday up
right because i know that all of a
sudden now we've got strong aggressive
buying coming in and then you know maybe
you're not convinced in this bar you
look at the next bar positive delta 300
okay then inside bar
here you know with negative delta then
positive positive positive more positive
delta coming in so you know that the
aggressive buyers are coming in at this
low
all right you could just see it
whoops wrong
you can see it manifesting right in here
so maybe you're not convinced in this
bar but even if you were it's going to
give you a great trade you're just
getting long here around the 90-ish area
yeah you're stopped here as opposed to
waiting for this market to break up
above you know the swing high or maybe
you've got a trend line coming in here
and you're getting long at you know at
05 would you rather get long at 90 or 05
but again if you weren't convinced in
this bar looking at the order flow
developing over these next couple of
bars here
is also bullish but you're not seeing it
on a normal candlestick chart on the
footprint chart you can see all that
information you can see
that big delta flip so to speak in this
bar
okay
now here's another one right this is
yesterday you have this
market going up it pulls back
here goes up pulls back again
and then takes off right it makes this
nice
strong mechanical move from 20 all the
way up into the 40s well
when the market is you don't know that
this is going to happen but when the
market is trading here you're wondering
okay are we going to keep going down you
know is this you know you draw your
swings you know one two three four five
you're going to look for the move you
know to come down below
4100 but it stopped here and then
reversed well why well if you're looking
at the order flow you can sort of see
why
right this is that pullback here this
this bar
is this bar right here okay
is this bar here
so you're coming in here okay nice
strong selling delta minus uh 1800
and then you got some positive deltas
here 95 700 600 and then some more
selling 300
400 and then two
okay
and then nice positive delta 378 480 614
so you know as you're selling off here
right all negative delta
as you start selling off again coming
into this low
yeah you got some selling
but it's weakening
you know it goes 344 447 it's kind of
even it's in just two
and then on the turn here it's 378 it's
positive
and then it rallies
all right and not only that but you're
seeing the delta get stronger
480 600 so you know that aggressive
buyers are coming in but more
importantly you know aggressive buyers
are coming in and
being very strong here
okay
and again that's the important thing of
recognizing what's happening in the
market right
hidden opportunity
is is hidden here in the delta right
you're seeing the delta weakening
could get back down to neutral of two
and then it's growing it's you know you
have a doji bar here it's 378 480 614.
all right so you could be getting long
in here at 22 rather than waiting for a
break out of this high up here at 30.
now the different types of orders that
give you an edge in the market well you
got to understand what the different
type of trading is right i explained
that a bit earlier
you know most traders don't think of the
types of orders that come into the
market they just think people buy and
people sell but there are different ways
to buy and sell something
there are passive buyers and sellers and
they're aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers
and the difference
recognizing the difference in them
is going to revolutionize your training
and you know and
most people don't think about this
i i touched on it earlier right if
you're looking at the dome
you have your passive buyers on this
side your passive sellers up here it
takes someone to cross the bid offer
to be aggressive
aggressive sellers
sell to the passive buyers
aggressive buyers buy from the passive
sellers because to be honest if everyone
was just working a bid in the offer in
the market
the market will never move they'll just
stay bid and offered
okay it's not going to go anywhere you
need someone to be aggressive you need
someone to lift the offer someone to hit
the bid that's what's going to move the
market right it's the cleaning out of
this 39 53
and making it 39.54 offer right that's
where the aggressive trading is coming
in you know if it's 39 53 and a quarter
and it's bid there the market's not
going to go lower until aggressive
sellers sell all the 53 and a quarters
start selling the 53s the twos and three
quarters that's what moves the markets
down the aggressive sellers it's not the
passive buyers that are moving the
markets down no they're happy to sit at
that price level you need the
aggressive traders to come in
so aggressive orders are market orders
obviously
orders that are
paying the offer price or selling at the
bid price
okay it's people that are cleaning out
the bids and the offers
the passive orders are the limit orders
to buy on the bid or below the bid
or the limit orders to sell at the offer
or above the offer
and
when you see these
aggressive trades happen
it's going to show up on a footprint now
it might be a little bit hard to see on
here but you see there's black numbers
in a bar and there's red and blue
numbers
black numbers are just your normal order
flow that's happening the red numbers
are aggressive cells and it's looking at
it in the two-way auction what's
happening the volume traded on the bid
versus the volume traded on the offer
and when you're seeing
you know sort of these clusters of
aggressive selling and clusters of
aggressive buying
you start to get a feel of which way
the market is going to move because you
know that markets move on aggressive
trading
so you're coming into the low right okay
you just make a new low you got some
aggressive sellers come in this is
probably a stop that got triggered right
here as you made a new low but then you
made a new low you start bouncing up and
you're seeing a lot of aggressive buying
all these blue numbers in a bar
so what do you think the market's going
to be doing right
you got all aggressive buying market is
probably going to keep going up
right this is where the aggressive
buying came in now it wasn't as dramatic
like a big move up but
knowing that you have aggressive buying
coming in here especially after a big
move down
well
after you have a big move down and all
of a sudden you see aggressive buying
coming in you know that that move lower
is probably over
right that's information that you can
use to position yourself
to find
a good trade right because now you're
going to be looking for long trades as
opposed to trading it from the short
side
you know when you get up towards a high
high of the day right here and you see
aggressive selling coming in you know as
the market is rallying you're expecting
to see aggressive buying right that's
why you see these bars with all these
blue volumes in here right because
that's the aggressive buying that's
taking place
then the market turns here and you have
aggressive selling right at the high of
the day you know it's a bar after the
high has been made but again this bar it
got within one tick of the high all of a
sudden you see aggressive selling coming
in
what do you think the trade is to take
oh i gotta get long
right you don't want to be fighting the
order flow you know there's aggressive
selling coming in you should be trading
it from the short side and what happens
the market sells off it doesn't keep
going up because now you know that there
is aggressive selling taking place in
the market so that's you know
understanding the different types of
orders you know the address the
difference between aggressive trading
market orders orders hitting the bid or
lifting the offer versus orders that are
just sitting on the order book which
don't move the
market now i'm going to share with you
some tips on how to use order flow data
so
there are many ways to use order flow in
your trading okay so look for trading
opportunities where there's a sudden
increase in buying or selling pressure
this usually indicates
a change in market direction right and
just as i was just telling you in the
form of imbalances is an easy way to do
it right this is the chart from earlier
pressure can come in the form of
imbalances either buying imbalances or
selling imbalances but you want to be
looking at
that in reference to where the market is
trading if a market is making new highs
and you're seeing buying and balances
okay that's what you expect to see but
if a market is making a new high and
you're seeing selling imbalances well
okay now i got a different form of
pressure coming in maybe this market
will react to that
and it often does because what you're
seeing now is a change in
um market perception right you're seeing
the aggressive selling coming in whereas
on the way up you're seeing the
aggressive buying come in
because if you're on a move up you have
aggressive buying what does that tell
you about moves down you have aggressive
selling and this is your first sign of
aggressive selling
you can also look at delta right you can
see what the change in
delta right because delta is the net
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers in a bar so while
imbalances
deal internally in the bar you know at
specific levels in a bar you know the
differences between aggressive buying
aggressive selling delta
gives you sort of the net net net for
the bar so as you can see here you're at
your low of the day but now the start
you see aggressive buying creep in
positive delta more positive delta more
positive delta it goes 52 54
192.
and the market does what it rallies
right because the aggressive buyers are
stepping in
at the low of the day
this is what we call a delta surge right
where the delta is
incrementally increasing
in a direction
now
the second tip i give you is be careful
extra careful when trading against
prevailing order flow if there's a
strong trend in place
it's likely that price will continue to
move in that direction right everyone
says
trend is your friend
well yeah trend is your friend so don't
trade against it and the same thing with
the order flow
right this was
tuesday i think market
got a full head of steam and you know
rallied you know from 41
oh 41 10 all the way up to 4140s right
you don't want to fight this you know
i'm going to get short here you know
there's people that like to sell highs i
got to get short here okay you didn't
stop that guy's short here it gets
stopped out don't fight it go with it
but you have to be able to recognize
that it's a go with market and
order flow is going to help you to
determine the conditions and there's a
condition that i described as a flow
driven market and what a flow driven
market is
it's when you have bearish order flow
okay if markets trending up like in this
case you have some signs in the order
flow that is potentially
bearish but then the market just runs
right over it when a market runs over
a certain type of order flow like
bullish or bearish it's telling you that
there are
bigger things at play in the market you
know more macro views
changing right because the simple thing
with order flow is is a delta divergence
right
like
delta divergence is when you're at a new
high or new low
and you have
um
opposite delta so you're in a new higher
you should have positive delta but if
you're at a new high you see negative
delta new high negative delta new high
negative delta because that's the first
sign of a potential change but if
you start seeing these deltas
divergences get taken out relatively
quickly you know the market is under a
full head of steam and trying to get
short there because there are people
that
will sell you a system for 500
that's just telling you to get short
when you have a new high and negative
delta or a new low and positive delta
well
okay on a normal rotational market
that's fine but on days where it's flow
driven right days where it's just
one way directional move
you're going to get stopped out you
stopped out stop down you have to be
able to recognize
pretty quickly that you're in a flow
driven market and one of the easiest
ways is when you see
bearish orderful come in
and it gets taken out in the next bar
like it was here and up here that
those are not you know
don't think of getting short in those
days you should be thinking getting
along you should be
turning the picture so to speak the duck
and the
and the rabbit picture to get a better
perspective of well okay i have my
bearish order flow the market's not
reacting the way it should chances are
it's a flow driven market
don't go against the flow
right we're up here at
at the high it's just sort of going
sideways
and you're seeing the aggressive selling
coming in here right all that negative
delta but in the bars you're seeing
the selling imbalances right so that's
telling you that you know what this
market is positioned to the short side
don't go against the flow
now
use order flow
to help confirm other technical
indicators right if you see a potential
trading opportunity on your charts check
the order flow to see if there's any
supporting evidence for your trade idea
so for example again it doesn't matter
what technical indicator you use i don't
use technical indicators i use order
flow but i know some people that do
right and
when their indicator turns down you know
crosses below the zero line or something
this is dmi
look at what's happening in the order
flow
just to give you that extra confirmation
okay we cross below the dm the zero line
yeah i see negative deltas okay it's
probably a good short
okay or bollinger bands right
i like
i i used to use bollinger bands many
years ago i don't anymore but when i mix
it with order flow i'm always looking
for these areas where i see support form
and points of controls give you nice
support and resistance levels i'm always
looking for support that just appears
you know right around a bollinger band
just to reinforce that hey you know what
that like here right because we could
cross through a bollinger band and keep
going down but when i see that support
form i'm looking for that move back
inside the bollinger band
so
you know
use order flow to help confirm
your
technical analysis
now
further the point
with technical analysis look at you know
support resistance levels
right it doesn't have to be you know you
don't have to
have fancy support and resistance levels
as long as you have basics of knowing
where support and resistance is
watch where
watch when the order flow trades around
those levels
okay because that's where you're going
to see you know our buyers stepping up
and defending their positions or
are you know if you're coming into a
support level are sellers really
interested in taking it through that
support level you know you're looking
for heavy volume looking for light
volume
and you know
one of the obvious support levels is you
know open high low close right so this
this is a support level right here this
line
and as the market came down in here you
traded a lot of volume it came down it
met that support and then it bounced up
from it right you had buyers down here
to absorb all the selling that was
happening
whereas here is the opposite now we're
coming into resistance
and initially there was some good volume
that was traded there but as you make a
second run into that resistance it only
trades five contracts now this is ten
years a five minute chart and normally
you're trading thousands of contracts
per price level all of a sudden you
trade five
well what's that telling us the traders
aren't interested at this level anymore
and the market reacted accordingly it
sold off if you know traders aren't
interested in taking this market higher
it only traded five contracts okay
what's the trade trade is to the
downside
now stacked imbalances right look for
stacked order flow imbalances an order
flow and balance occurs when there are
more buyers more buy orders and sell
orders vice versa
to trade a stacked order and balance is
when there are three or more imbalances
stacked neatly on top of each other now
order flow and balances indicate that
the market is about to move in a
particular direction and can be used to
make trading decisions so here's a
market that was mostly going sideways as
it starts breaking out you got to stack
selling imbalance well i know that
aggressive sellers now are rushing for
the exit door i got to get out of this
trade you know everyone that was buying
it
trying to get long is now rushing to
sell it to get out right as the market
starts dropping and eventually
goes
lower and lower okay right here
again market hit a new low the stack's
selling in balance okay maybe it's a
stop that got triggered that's what you
would expect a new low
but
as the market starts bouncing back you
got stacked by an imbalance aggressive
buyers are coming into the market
so let the market tell you what the best
opportunities are and give you that's
going to give you an edge over other
traders
so let me share with you a couple of
successful strategies for trading order
flow
now there are many different strategies
that can be used when trading order for
and people ask me is mike what's the
best strategy
and to be honest i have many different
strategies of looking at the order flow
because the market conditions are so
dynamic they're always changing okay
there's no
you know markets are fractal right you
get things that look alike but there's
no two exactly the same and market
conditions change sometimes you're in a
trendy market sometimes you're in a
consolidating market sometimes you're in
a range bond market it really depends
and
you're gonna see look for different
things in different market conditions
but here are three there's actually two
aggressive selling near a high or
aggressive buying near a low delta
weakness at highs or lows so there's two
right aggressive selling
and delta weakness so
aggressive selling near a high or
aggressive buying near a low the market
has just put in a move up or down and is
now attracting traders to come in and
participate look at the delta look at
the imbalances
okay so here e-mini's just made a new
high
and then what do you see do you see
aggressive buying still no you're seeing
aggressive selling coming in you're
seeing selling imbalances in the bars
two
okay what do you think the trade is so
the downside it's not to the upside you
know you're at your high aggressive
sellers are coming in
both
by looking at the imbalances by looking
at the delta
what's happening on this pullback
well you pulled back you got some
aggressive selling great but now you got
a body's got one two three aggressive
buys aggressive buyers are coming it's
got the positive delta your negative
delta is gone it's flipped to positive
delta right what do you think the trade
is it's to the upside
keep it simple right you just follow the
direction of the imbalances
mark is coming off selling imbalances
market starts to rally buying imbalances
markets coming off selling it balances
market starts to rally you're seeing
buying imbalances look at the deltas
negative deltas as the market moves down
positive deltas as the market moves up
negative deltas as the market's moving
down positive deltas as the market
starts moving up
now the second one is delta weakness at
highs and lows so as the market is
making new highs or lows how is delta
acting is it stronger directionally or
is it weakening
if the delta is weakening
the move is probably over but when i
talk about weakening i'm talking about
is it still strong are you making new
highs on strong positive delta or is it
kind of petering out so here's this
market is rallying it's a five minute
chart as this market is rallying up nice
positive deltas eleven hundred fourteen
hundred
and you see negative delta start
creeping in these you know aggressive
sellers are coming in
800 400
and then positive again 542 a new high
yay but delta's only 40.
okay that's a sign of weakness you're at
your high
where's the aggressive buyers why aren't
they coming in and this bar actually had
positive
952 delta max delta and then it closed
at 40. so it gave back
almost a thousand 900
of its aggressive buying turns to
aggressive selling and then you make a
new high here negative delta a strong
negative delta 500
so you know that
the positive delta is weakening and now
you're starting to see the negative
delta creep in what do you think the
trade is it's to the downside it's not
to the upside
here market is selling off right it's
nice selloff right nice strong negative
deltas 400 500 300 then positive 600
and then just negative 50 uh 94.
then at the low big positive delta 1200
this 1200
is you know almost your strongest delta
one way or the other going back to this
bar which is two thousand but one two
three four five six seven eight nine
over the last nine bars it's your
strongest delta but it's positive do you
think this market is going to still go
down no
trade is to the upside
now this is ten years
similar action markets moving up nice
positive deltas high of the day
right it's a double top here
delta minus seven thousand
this is your strongest delta one way or
the other
over any other delta on this chart and
it's
negative what do you think the market's
going to do i think the market is going
to still go up no
chances are the market's going to sell
off
which it did you know and that's how
using this information that's available
to you it's there for you you don't need
level two data you don't need level
three or level four just the simple top
level data but you need a way
to organize it that you can use it in
your training
so over the last 45 minutes or so i've
covered a lot of ground
right you've learned
about the basics of order flow trading
and hopefully you've seen how it can
help you make better trading decisions
you should have also learned about some
of the key tools and resources that are
available to order flow traders
so hopefully you
will agree this has been time well spent
i i think so
it's in just a short amount of time
we've covered
a lot about a complex topic right about
understanding what you're seeing in the
order flow now of course i can't cover
everything in a quick training session
like this i wish i could
but there's so much to more to learn
about order flow trading
and i hope now you have a good
understanding of order flow basics and
if you're interested in learning more i
got a special deal for you a special
offer
you know you took the time out to
watch this training today you know i
want to give you something to make it
worth your while
and you can be excited the order flow
trader software which you've seen
in this presentation in this training
i got a special deal for you on how to
get it so if you've ever felt like
you're struggling to understand
something only to have it click into
place and suddenly become easy that's
the power of understanding how something
works once you understand the underlying
principles life becomes much easier take
trading for example if you don't
understand how training works it can be
very confusing and frustrating and the
order flows trader software is like
taking
you know the the
all the knowledge that i've gained in 25
years of trading at an institutional
level and putting it into a software so
you could see what's happening in the
market and more importantly understand
it and trade that what you're seeing
so
the thing is software is one part of
trading right it's one thing to have
software but you have to know
how to use the software if you don't
it's going to be pointless right that's
why i focus on providing a lot of
education
on how to trade with order flow right
because i want you my students to be
successful i want you to know that
starts with giving you the tools you
need to understand the market not just
oh here's software go figure it out on
your own no here's software here's how
to use it right a lot of instructional
videos
a lot of training even live training
which i'll get to in a second
so when you get my order flow software
i'm going to also give you access to my
order flow trading course for free which
i sell for 297 every day on my website
but also give you access to my order
flow inner circle video series it's 56
videos with advanced order flow tricks
tips and forms of analysis and you can
only get it now
through this special offer you can't buy
this on my website
now the software i normally sell it for
8.99
it runs on ninjatrader it's very easy to
set up the training is 297.
the inner circle video series is 497.
that's 1600 yeah it's a commitment but
you're not going to pay that much as
long as you're willing to make that
commitment i'm willing to knock off a
lot of that price
now again i realize it's one thing to
learn from videos and training sessions
like this
but what really takes traders to the
next level is
live
training
and each tuesday
i do a live training session from 7 p.m
to 8 p.m central time
and i've been doing this for the last
three years since i started doing this
you're seeing some other companies
starting to offer things like that but
in the past nobody ever did
and you know people i realized how
important this was to trader development
by having a live session where traders
can come in and ask me anything about
the markets or or the software or order
flow
and if you can't attend it live there's
replays we've got over 170 replays now
here it says 157 but it's it's up to
over 170 already
and again you could watch the replay if
you can't attend live you know and you
if there's something you want me to
discuss you can either ask it live or
you can shoot me an email and i'll talk
it about it in the training room
now some people charge you know 200
and more a month for this
you're going to get that for free i
don't charge for it it's a free resource
for
users of the order flow trader software
and what i discussed today is just a
small sample of kinds of things i talk
about on a weekly basis in the live
group training
or what you can find in my inner circle
video series but i go into much more
detail about all aspects of trading from
technical analysis fundamentals
i talk about different training
strategies i use how to adapt them and
changing marketing conditions and much
more it's really an open forum to
discuss whatever
you like
okay so to get my order flows trader
software go to order flows.com
slash off five
put the link in the chat just scroll
down
all right it's going to take you to this
but now there's some videos you could
watch and you can see it's only going to
cost us a one-time payment of 7.49
right you're not paying sixteen hundred
dollars as i explained earlier you're
paying 749 it's almost a thousand
dollars off you get access to the order
flows trader software the order flow
training course
the inner circle video series
weekly live group trainings and as a
special bonus i'll give you my order
flows playbook trading course
so just go to this button here click on
that button by now it's going to take
you to paypal paypal processes your
payment i don't do it paypal does all
that for you
just check your email that you have
registered with paypal because that's
where all the download information and
course logins and license tokens are
going to
go be sent to
and it's just a one-time payment of 749.
so go to orderflows.com5.html
there's no monthly recurring payments
you're not i'm not or yearly you know
you're not in one year and i could get
charged again
you know another 749 no it's just a
one-time payment now you do need to pay
your data fees that's outside of me and
your ninjatrader fees
okay so
just bear that in mind that there are
some
fees you know to run the software like
on the trading platform ninjatrader that
you're gonna have to do now it will run
on the free version of ninjatrader as
well
people ask me that all the time if you
want to say you're executing trades
through
a different front end but you just want
to use ninjatrader as your
charting platform you can do that you
can download the free ninjatrader
version get my software install it you
just need a live data feed
so as a special bonus for investors expo
and give you access to my order flow
playbook which i normally sell for 297.
you get that for free it's a nice course
on trading with the order flow
it's more of an advanced course
but you can get it for free there's
about 10 or 11 additional trade setups
in there that you can take advantage of
so get started now go to orderflows.com
and
get going so what you're going to get is
the order flow trader software normally
it's 8.99 the order flow trading course
which is normally 297.
the order inner circle video series
which is 497.
the access to the join the live weekly
group trainings you know again i don't
want to put a price on it but if i were
it easily be 200 a month
and you get access to the order flow
playbook which is normally 297 you get
that as well for free
so just go to
orderflows.com5.html it's just a
one-time payment
now
early on i discussed that i had written
a book on trading with order flow
and if you want to get that book
go to
orderflows.combook.html it's a 150 page
book you're not going to get the actual
hardcover you're going to get access to
the digital download just enter your
name and email and hit submit and you'll
be taken to the page that you can
download it
so
get started now with the order flow
trader software go to order flows dot
com slash off five dot html
and i'll see you guys on the inside yeah
i got a couple minutes here
um
i'll take a look at this
questions here
real quick
yeah you know if you use
tos i mean you could like i said you
could use the free version a ninjatrader
and just put my software on it and you
could just get a data feed for it
i get here late looks interesting yeah
there will be a replay
let's see great at this but
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
takes place in the same time no
don't take place at the same time
aggressive buyers
buy from passive sellers aggressive
sellers sell to passive buyers
so remember there's bids and offers
right the bids and offers
are
passive traders right the bid is the
passive buyer the offer is a passive
seller so when someone crosses the bid
offer line
is when they become aggressive
um
do i use this on a one-minute chart yeah
i use
one-minute chart i actually use
30-second charts as well i use
five-minute charts um in some markets i
do keep an eye on 15-minute charts i
also use tick based charts i used to use
range based charts but the markets are
moving a bit faster now over the last
couple years that's why i sort of went
back to time based charts
yeah do i use any confirmation besides
delta yeah i do there's just not enough
time to get into it
um yeah order flow is all about the
volume inside the candles yeah because
you know you're watching it how
the trading is happening inside
of the bar so to speak think of it as
you know
there's no more open outcry trading pits
but imagine if you're standing on the
trading floor what you're looking at in
the order flow footprint chart is
essentially what was happening
you could see where the buying is where
the strong buying is where there's price
and defense you know if there's a big
bidder in the market right and that's
just information you don't see on a
normal um bar chart
all right guys i kept you here for about
an hour i'll leave it there so again you
know just go to
orderflows.com5 to get started and i'll
see you guys on the inside
so thanks anna thanks for having me and
again thanks everybody for taking some
time out of your busy days and i hope to
hear from you guys soon bye bye